- Now I want to say the
level of disrespect,
but I believe that HR
people need to believe
in themselves more and
have a bigger impact.
Look at this guy, whaaaat?
Right there.
That's the Eiffel Tower.
- He's not taking us.
- France, not the best place to travel to
when you are on a calorie restriction.
What's up Believe Nation?
Happy weekend.
I am on my way to Paris, and
I'm taking you guys with me.
- Not us.
He's not taking us.
- [Evan] Not Nina.
Not Nina.
- Not me.
- Or the dog.
- [Evan] Not Haden.
- [Nina] Or Haden.
- But you guys get to come.
(upbeat music)
(cheerful music)
So I'm going to be speaking at an event
in Paris for a company called Talentsoft
and talking about the role of digital and
leadership for the human-resource
industry, which is great.
It came as a result of somebody that I
worked with at Sage, who left Sage
and went off to go to Talentsoft.
And this happens a lot in B2B businesses.
If you're selling to business, you want
to make sure you have a great relationship
with everybody involved,
because it's so often
that people will jump from
one company to another.
And if you had a great relationship,
they're going to bring you with 'em.
So I'm excited to go.
I haven't been to Paris for, I want
to say, five or six years.
Last time I went was with Nina.
And so, I'm at the airport,
a little bit early.
Going to check in.
Fighting some allergies,
so hopefully those go away.
And I'm ready to have a great time.
(cheerful music)
It's one of the benefits about flying
business class, which I
do for my corporate stuff.
You get to go to the airport
lounges before taking off.
So I got to find mine, relax, do a little
bit of work, say hi to
Nina, then hop my flight.
(cheerful music)
So if you noticed from my
food, eatin' pretty light.
I'm on a special new diet that my
personal trainer put me on.
(sniffs)
Ooh, allergies.
And I have to track
calories on a daily basis.
So a lot of the stuff in there, I have
no idea what it was, so I'm going to go
find myself a Booster Juice downstairs.
France, not the best place to travel
to when you are on a calorie restriction.
(laughs)
We'll see how it goes, and I'll
try to guess as best I can.
(cheerful music)
Alright, got my Bananas Away.
Oh.
It's good stuff.
370 calories gives me,
like, six-hundy-something
left for the flight.
Fingers crossed.
I got a little bit of (mumbles)
time before I check in.
So I'm going to do some social media.
I love answering people's questions
on my phone, I'm on Twitter, Instagram,
Snapchat at airports, flying.
It's a great way to kill time and
add some value to the community.
(cheerful music)
I was, uh, forgot to check in.
I was the last to check
in in business class,
so I get the middle seat, but this
is going to be pretty comfortable.
I got good news.
The guys next to me
are traveling together.
So I don't have to sit
in the middle anymore.
(new age music)
(upbeat music)
Alright, landed in Paris.
Ooh, these chairs are cool.
Check this out.
Those lie-down chairs in
the plane were awesome.
Couldn't sleep, though.
Mix of congestion and
the guy coughing nonstop.
I feel bad for the cougher.
Seven hours straight.
Must be rough.
Anyway, happy to be here in Paris.
Going to go find my Uber driver, I guess.
There's some driver picking me up.
I'm going to get to the hotel and
try to get a little bit of sleep.
It is seven in the morning, Paris time,
and I'm looking forward
to starting this day.
(upbeat music)
This crazy line is the exit.
I guess Customs is not going to find
(drowned out by background
noise) anytime soon.
So I'm standing in that crazy line.
It gives me a chance to answer
some messages on social media.
Alright, finally got out.
That took at least an hour.
That was crazy.
Just got a message that my driver is here,
waiting for me, worried that I'm not
showing up, so I got to go find him.
Very excited to get to
the hotel and sleep.
(fast-paced music)
Alright, I'm all checked in.
Number 6083, ready to go
up, check out my room.
So people like Xavier, who set me up here,
my client, my friend,
asked me how my flight was.
So on the one hand, the
flight wasn't that great,
you know, no wi-fi,
the TV system went down
and lost my spot in the movie.
I couldn't sleep because of my allergies,
couldn't sleep because this guy was
coughing ahead of me the whole night,
so, you know, not the best experience.
But on the other hand, the food was great,
I got to sit on the aisle because that guy
wanted to sit with his friend, you know,
I got those awesome seats that reclined.
And overall, it was a
good experience, and so
was it a good flight, was it a bad flight?
Well, it was both.
It really just depends on what
side of the coin you look at it.
I think that applies to most
of the things in our lives.
It's 10:30.
I got here at 7:00.
It's been three-and-a-half hours
through security and
everything else to get here.
And I'm grateful, I'm happy.
I'm ready to sleep, but I'm happy
to be in the hotel, I have a place to go.
And so with every
situation, there's always
something you can find that's negative,
and there's always something
you can find that's positive.
Is it a good flight or a bad flight?
Is that thing you're facing
right now good or bad, too?
It just depends on your outlook.
Try to look on the positive side.
Think it may help.
Think I'm here, 6082.
Look at these doors.
Ahahahahaha.
Alright.
Look at this.
Bathroom with
That's pretty funky to have in the shower.
Got a nice bathroom.
Look at that guy, whaaaat?
Let's go in.
Oh, I've got two little beds.
That's cool.
Maybe I can squish 'em together.
Got my TV, get some CNN on.
Look at those lamps.
That's pretty cool.
Oh, these are those showers that are,
it's kind of a little bit see-through.
You can't actually see through,
but the light gets through.
Look at this view.
Paris, (speaking French)
How is it?
(speaking French)
Oh, man, my French, my
French has to come back.
Alright, so we're going to set up,
have a quick nap, see how much
time I have left afterwards, and
practice my speak, go see Xavier.
If I have a little bit of time,
go check out some of the scenes
around here, take you guys with me.
(gentle music)
Alright, so, got about
five hours' nap there.
Wanted to sleep more, but I had to
get up, because if I had a huge sleep,
then I wouldn't sleep tonight,
and tomorrow is an important day.
Presentation day.
So I've got a couple hours before
meeting Xavier and going to dinner,
which is interesting, because it's, like,
10 o'clock in the morning for me.
So I'm going to head onto the town,
practice what I'm going to be thinking
about for my speech, take in some
of the sights, and have some fun.
(leisurely Parisian music)
So, figuring out the French
subway system has been fun.
(laughs)
Did a couple of wrong turns, but
I think I finally know where I'm going.
And I'm heading to the Champs-Elysees,
the most famous street in France,
and I'm going to check
out the, what's it called?
Arc de Triomphe.
The Arch of Triumph.
(leisurely Parisian music)
So just behind me, oh, this side,
right there, that's the Eiffel Tower.
And seeing it, seeing back
there makes me miss Nina.
Last time we came here, it
was, uh, it was a big surprise.
We are off to Paris, France.
- No. What?
- [Evan] And we're on the
way to the airport right now.
- Are you serious?
- [Evan] Yeah.
- Oh, my God, are you serious?
(Evan laughs)
No way.
- I just showed up at her work.
I booked an extra day off of her work,
and we went for the weekend and came.
It was Nina's first time to Paris.
And I'm missing her right now.
I hope she's doing okay.
I got to bring her back now.
It's a sign, I got to bring her back.
Nina, I got to bring you back here.
Got to bring you back here.
Love you.
(leisurely Parisian music)
So they've really beefed up security
since I came here last time.
You can't even get in around the tower
without security getting to the gates.
It never used to be gated off like this.
You had to pay to kind of go up
to the various levels of the Eiffel Tower,
but now you can't even get inside
or close to it without
going through security.
(drowned out by background noise)
things you're not allowed to bring in.
It's a little sad.
It's a little sad that
it's kind of come to that.
Hopefully it's a temporary
thing, but, uh, yeah.
So I'm not going to go in.
I don't have time to stand in line.
I got to get back, got to have a shower,
and then meet up with Xavier.
I remember when I came here with Nina.
I'm still at the Eiffel Tower.
There it is.
There were these flowers here,
and Nina wanted to stop and look
at them and just appreciate them.
And that's what Nina loves doing.
She loves appreciating nature
and appreciating the flowers.
One of these bushes, I think
it's this bush, actually.
You know, when I travel for business,
I don't really do a lot
of the touristy things.
I don't really need to.
I'm not like, "Oh, my God,
it's the Eiffel Tower!"
But I've been here a number of times
already, too, so it's probably it.
I'm a mix, so far, when
I'm doing this stuff, of
one, just focusing on my
talk, what I'm going to say.
You know, I'm missing four days for this,
so I better deliver some
serious value tomorrow
at my speech or I wasted my time here.
And I always put that pressure on myself.
So I got one side there.
But the other side, I
just, I'm missing Nina
A lot.
I mean, I knew I'd miss her, but I'm
missing her a lot more than I expected.
I guess because of the history that we
have here in this city and how I brought
her here and the fun times we had.
Don't want to travel without Nina.
I'm missing her a lot.
Anyway.
Going to hop in the subway,
head back to the hotel,
and have a quick shower, meet up
with Xavier, and go for dinner.
(fast-paced club music)
It's a McDonald's over there.
One of the things that
I always used to do.
I wouldn't really care about
food in cities until Nina.
I still don't really care that much.
Just every time I travel,
now I need to book
food in, because Nina loves
trying the local stuff.
I would much rather just go in, just
chill the city, see as
much stuff as possible,
and stopping into a restaurant
seemed to be, like, a waste of time.
(laughs)
I'm still not a huge fan,
but I would do it for Nina.
But anyway, McDonald's used to
always be my home when I traveled.
Just in, out, try something
kind of, "kind of" local.
I was always curious to see what
they had that was different.
McDonald's and Starbucks.
So they had a blue-cheese bacon burger.
I hate blue cheese.
But even just thinking, it's what
I always used to do, go to McDonald's
and check out what's new and different
and try that and take off, but, uh.
I made it back.
I've got 10 minutes to go.
And I'm excited.
(gentle music)
Alright, had a great shower.
Relaxed a little bit.
Thought about what I was going to
say tomorrow, refine my
speech, change my shirt.
Totally different shirt.
Look at that amazing shirt.
And now I'm going to
meet Xavier in the lobby.
(gentle music)
There he is, Mr. Xavier.
How you doin'?
- Hi, (mumbles).
- (laughs) Boom.
How you doin', man?
(gentle music)
I'm here on the Champs-Elysees
with the founders of Talentsoft.
There's one.
Got more in the back, behind.
Going to go have some
dinner, have some good talk.
So excited.
(calm, upbeat music)
Now I want to say the level of disrespect,
but I believe that HR
people need to believe
in themselves more and
have a bigger impact.
I'm frustrated that more CEOs
don't come from HR positions.
You know, especially
North America (mumbles)
doesn't come from HR, and I believe that
we shouldn't just be complaining about it,
we should be the leaders
and be the change.
And tomorrow I'm going to go over some
new ideas that I have that may
help you guys on your path.
(audience laughs)
And it's an honor to be here, and I've
had some great discussions, and I see
a lot of talent, a lot of
leadership in this room,
and I hope that you'll
take the information
that you learn tomorrow back home
to your companies, and
I'm really just hoping
to make a mark on your industry.
- Thank you, Evan.
- [Woman] Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- Great group, great dinner.
Some really awesome
conversations, actually.
I taught people the handshake, pushed
people to do bigger, bolder things,
you know, usual Believe kind of stuff.
It's, I don't know what time it is.
I want to say 11 o'clock, Paris time.
Ooh, I also got some macaroons.
Look at this.
Some yummy French macaroons.
I probably destroyed my
calorie intake for the day.
I'm going to head back to the hotel,
probably practice my speech one more time,
go through based on the new
information I kind of got today.
I love really tailoring the content
that I'm putting out, depending on
the people, depending on the audience.
So it's always great to be able to
connect with the audience a little bit
in advance, to just feel them out,
hear what their challenges
are, and you can
create something much better than just the
standard thing that you
might deliver at an event.
So that was good.
So I'm going to rejig it a little bit,
practice, see if I can get a hold of Nina,
what she's up to, head to bed, wake up
tomorrow morning, and let's go crush it.